My toddler stumbled into my room this morning
asking for cereal for breakfast.
He saw someone eating Fruit Loops and wanted those specifically,
so I caved and just made her some.
Started by combining some almond flour,
maple syrup, coconut oil,
and some tapioca flour giving that a good mix.
Setting that aside
and then got started on grinding up all of my dried fruit,
I decided on a mango banana flavor,
raspberry flavor, and also blueberry since that's her favorite fruit.
My cereal dough into each bowl
added a little bit more flour and gave that a really good mix.
Once it all came together,
I started forming my little cereal by getting a small amount of dough,
rolling it out, and placing it on a Parchment paper lined baking sheet.
While I was doing that, I also preheated my oven to about 350 degrees,
and once that was ready,
I smashed down my cereal and added a little hole in the middle.
Before baking them for about eight to 10 minutes,
I let them cool completely,
topped them with some milk,
and she absolutely loved them.